hi friends let's get you caught up on
the shiny oh hell no that movie was
scary ah Stephen King and ready for the
continued story in dr. sleep the shining
it's about a boy named Danny who goes
through a super creepy hotel with his
parents
this kid has psychic powers and his dad
goes back crazy and tries to kill him
and his mom crazy stuff happens to Danny
we're talking creepy twins a crazy maze
the ghost of a dead lady in a bathtub
alrighty so fast-forward to dr. sleep
it's 40 years late Danny has grown up
and working at a hospital
Danny's special psychic ability aka his
shine never went away the shine is real
it's big and it tells him what his
patients are gonna die so he gets the
nickname dr. sleep Danny's hearing
voices mostly from dead people then a
little girl named Abra pops into his
head asking for help
oh she's got the shine to twist I don't
know about magic
I was called at the shining Danny and
Abra get together to try and defeat the
true not a seriously bad crew led by
Rose the half a group of vicious
drifters who ruthlessly hunt innocent
children who have to shine the only way
to do that is to go back to the heart
and soul of his trauma the place where
it all started the Overlook Hotel will
Danny and Abra be able to face their
fears or will the true nots prevail I'm
over for more twins I'm hoping for more
blood you can see all that go down in
theaters on November 8 when you check
out dr. sleep